welcome to ETS can't down to the royal
wedding i'm lauren zima and we have got
14 weeks everybody until megan and harry
tie the knot so I'm really brushing up
on my British terms and if you're
feeling a bit knackered or as if things
are going all to pot well we are here to
invite you into the lives of the Royals
for a few moments where everything is
hunky-dory
so wedding planning where are we at well
the latest on Prince Harry and Megan
Marcos plans is some instruction on
gifting guests mate grapple with the
question what do I buy the perfect
Prince and his perfect bride for their
perfect wedding an ice bucket KitchenAid
mixer monograms towels
certainly not as much as we know that
Harry and Megan do love their activities
around the house
typical gifts just won't do but not to
worry according to the Daily Mail guests
will be asked to donate to a charitable
fund in lieu of gifts will and Kate
pictured here did that same thing back
in 2011 yes and the public could donate
and they also contributed sales from
their own royal wedding album so
ultimately they raised more than 1
million pounds for 26 charities now no
one has to worry about waiting until the
last minute when you know all that's
left on the registry are two washcloths
and an egg timer and you're that person
and a source tells et that invites
should go out within the next few weeks
but there is a bit of regal ruckus the
invite list so Sarah Ferguson you'll
remember her she's been divorced from
Prince Andrew Prince Charles's brother
for more than 20 years and some outlets
are reporting that she will not be
invited to Harry and Megan's wedding she
did not attend Will and Kate's wedding
but here's the thing Harry is very close
with her daughter his cousin Princess
Eugenie and we have answers our source
tells us Fergie
will at least be invited Princess
Eugenie actually just got engaged
herself our source
says that Eugenie and her fiance Jack
are close friends with Harry and Megan
and have even double-dated with them
they will also get married on the same
grounds as Harry and Megan means our
Castle of course that's gonna be months
later in October because we can not
interfere with Harry and Megan let's
move into our royal rapport and this
week guys Hollywood weighs in I'm a Brit
he's like that he's like the cool fun
Prince do I mean all my friends are like
since we've been growing up it's like
Harry we want to hang out with area
because you're not in our culture it's
like Prince Harry's like untouchable
that is fifty Shades freed star Rita Ora
chatting with et about Prince Harry and
she's right back in the day
pre-engagement Harry was a bit of a
partier but she saw him at Kensington
Palace just a few months ago I kept a
respectful and I'm respectful of his
wedding which I think is gonna be so
good oh gosh like today I love I'm crazy
you know I do love the royal family I
love everything about them today so I
think it's really nice to see him happy
and everything making sense but as a kid
it's like everyone wanted to hang out
with Harry because he was the fun one
plus I spoke with another friend to the
Royals Dame Helen Mirren who famously
played Harry and Will's grandmother the
Queen in the movie the Queen what advice
do you have for Megan Markel as she
becomes part of the royal family I don't
think she needs any advice I have to say
that she's being so charming and so
dignified in the right sort of way in a
natural kind of a way I think she's
absolutely kind of naturally got what it
takes and I think I think she's a really
wonderful addition to the royal family
and she's very beloved already and I'm
in England Helen Mirren actually is a
real Queen in my mind guys and last a
cast a few weeks ago lifetime announced
that they will chronicle Harry and
Megan's romance in a new unauthorised
made-for-tv movie and they have now
revealed the cast of the two leads
forgive me if I'm saying this wrong but
Carissa Fitz Henley and Maury Fraser
will play Megan and Harry and Harry and
Megan a royal love story filming starts
in just a few days in Vancouver and in
Los Angeles but what do you guys think
do
used to look the parts let us know in
the comments below
lifetime did a similar movie about Will
and Kate back in 2011 premiering it just
a few weeks before their wedding
and as for willing Kate's whereabouts
after their royal visits to Sweden and
Norway last week they are now back in
England which takes us to our rather
regal looks of the week and everyone I
have a conspiracy theory I'm wearing
blue for a reason today because it's all
Kate's been wearing lately if we look at
the Duchess's duds over the past week
and trust me I spent a lot of time doing
that you'll see a trend blue and this
has me wondering does Kate have a case
of the Blues because she's expecting a
baby boy such a blessing children Kate
is continuing her campaign for mental
health awareness the palace released
this new PSA featuring her and notice
she's wearing a blue printed Sarafine
maternity dress she's actually worn it
several other times during her other
pregnancies just love when Kate recycled
her fabulous clothes she wore blue again
yesterday in a coat by goat yes the
brand's name is goat but you can get
that coat on sale right now by the way
Kate was there helping with the opening
of a new addiction treatment center in a
local community so what's your
prediction will Will and Kate's third
child be a boy or a girl let us know in
the comments below and we are going to
end on some highborn humour everybody
this week a blunder Megan was at the
mercy of a mix-up as she presented at
the endeavour fund awards some papers
got switched around but she used those
acting skills and powered through
well I thought Megan handled that moment
with plenty of princess like grace but
her outfit from the event is actually
causing a stir even days later because
she wore pants what do you guys think
did you like this Alexander McQueen look
or was it too casual and maybe she
should have been dressed a bit more
queenly let us know in the comments
below and come back next Friday
everybody for all things royal as we
continue to countdown to the Royal
Wedding cheerio
[Music]